let's let's get going ok so let's see
how it is how it is now I switched to
30fps and it should it should hopefully
improve things
so underlay is playing a bit of a
rillette weird line but I'm not sure
that I'm refuting it really I should be
okay but I haven't refuted it okay let's
do it like this
so I've got the better position but
nothing much
yeah with the bishop I should be should
be fine so some feedback would be cool
if things have improved or not
yeah I tried to put this on this on to
f3 okay maybe I'm trying to do too much
him I mean I had a good position anyhow
not sure that I needed to play this
ambitiously yeah those two points should
be extremely strong I'm just going to
put books on the G file now that should
work nice nicely FPS folks per second
yes probably
[Music]
I have to support the develop on okay
now what to do this this looks fine
[Music]
you should be poised the thing taking 1
G 2 this should do the trick
no it's 30fps now you probably don't
notice a real difference oh this is all
covered
huh
[Music]
it's sick but somehow he's back in this
game
and now I'm threatening discoveries all
kinds of discoveries okay yeah I don't
think it meted all that much Saturday
that has stopped the stream for a couple
of seconds and yeah thanks about for
subscribing yeah getting irritated here
would rego Donny
no he's berserk okay I mean I would have
deserved him back which I couldn't it
was just over this option was not
available for me anymore
Wow
thanks for the cheer that's great huge
cheer my numero foe
excellent Thanks so yeah he's he has
done the berserk
which is cool now I know that winning on
time is a very serious option give me
maybe I should have taken a ruku c6
that's a lot a lot quicker
near g6 I can take yeah this looks
decent like a decent move from black
going to have six probably know after
this trade it will become quite easy to
continue I think I can take that winter
5 is almost the same thing and now
trying to go with 95 got the chick go
through f3 coming try to play for mate
yeah there was a bit of a suicidal
boozer King I guess yeah I'm close to
the top ten but Taheri is on 47 bunch is
crazy but I will just try and see see
what happens I'm playing intent to play
the full hours so it's always possible
that somebody is not playing the whole
tournament so a high score at the moment
does not mean that it has to this has to
a continue the whole time
Knight age 4 I could move I wanted to
try to play a 5 but this is difficult to
do now
[Music]
there's the minimum amount of time that
you can play you can join and leave the
tournament as you wish why is a lot
better him a lot better the only chance
I have is to try to shut it down
completely like this but yeah he's
taking and this is better of course than
not doing this very good for white
disposition he played an interesting
line this is actually a line that I
recently looked at and it's it's it's
very very much worth trying out white I
mean
I have been playing since the beginning
of this tournament yes the only thing
that I'm reasonably happy with is them
the time management
I was playing quickly and this helped me
a little bit at least
threatening me for now yeah maybe he
hasn't done this in the best possible
way maybe is very certain he hasn't done
it in the best best possible way because
I was really in in terrible shape and
this this looks somewhat playable at
least
have three orders no I've got Queen iya
three coming walk or King here I've got
Queen g3 that looks like a win gets made
yeah I swindled myself somehow out of
this or he screwed up there's two ways
of seeing it how can you be on second
place with the 2000 blitz raiding him
that's really funny that's that's a
great score that's a new account or
something I don't know I was all the
theory everything
well why does better him why does better
him I I somehow night here what is the
deal here I forgot how this is played
right him yeah not happy in 95 is better
for white yep why do I just a better
position here not happy about the
caption F for maybe I didn't have a have
a way to go there's a bit Foursquare to
go okay
let's see if I can hold on yeah again
I'm definitely worse and worse a lot
before my idea to get at the b2 pawn at
the end what could go be for himself not
so possible
[Music]
yeah
ninety-five
[Music]
95m okay
before I will take not just one cheek
yeah I said I mean that's not a good
good ending but maybe you can fight at
least beat us a check it's not not so
easy to do from white
Jim
no not good it's really not good here
[Music]
yeah that was too good for me that mm
player was playing fantastically well
okay so let's see so many points behind
to lead yeah that's crazy
it is a big cup no it's not what guy if
I have some team okay so
who is playing like that I don't know
going voluntarily into this but okay it
seems to be okay
no no whiskey just some regular Roy boss
as I leaned as I learned as I learned it
has to be pronounced okay let's see if I
can gain a bit of space yeah it is not
TM by strict standards
[Music]
so I've tried to gain a bit of space and
got control over the D farm I'm
certainly a bit better but it's still
not easy to make something out of it
something concrete like to trade Queens
the Queen honey voids extremely annoying
but it's not easy to do I have no no BS
around really don't I was probably a
silly move but should be three yeah no
it should not sure that helped
okay that is a move I did not have on
the radio at all doing this all too well
it's probably just equal
there's still this pressure one on b2
that is extremely annoying you know at
least this is all one this position I
think is roughly equal it'd be five I
have c5 I don't think this would would
help him can always try to trade stuff
b5 there's still c5 I now have Queen d1
as an idea which is not doing much but
it looks a little bit like a threat
rooty 7 it's probably nothing much
Bishop g5 is also a possible idea trying
to trade this get to get to d8 yeah this
is a thing to try
okay so this notice blunders blunder
Steve form
[Music]
rook c5 now like a normal I can almost
take and then g6 this is what I'm doing
it's crazy I just should pleasure just
play a normal move it's not super easy
for him to play but the time that's a
huge gamble
okay there was very dirty but well three
minutes yes sir and now my blitz rating
is really low I don't play blitz often
and often I do against viewers so it's
difficult to get this get this rating up
yeah I went into to hustle my there I
wasn't really good chess but you need
some wins it's crazy how far away from
the top players really I mean I don't
playing well but still okay I had to
activate this annoyed
maybe this to c5 these three was was
hanging here I could have just taken
this very silly now I get to deform okay
I start to like this pollution those
Knights look good
very powerful looking pieces them one c5
and d4 okay yep Bishop g4 it somehow won
the cards maybe each floor as well
f1 see many moves for my opponent
hey it's not a good sign okay that looks
okay now I have to is hanging at Queen
he also has a queen Reuters just sort of
squares their way to trap the Queen here
maybe this month I take the rook I know
my book is saying as well of it okay
that looks okay yeah I think I should
win this one and there was a mistake I
didn't even see that he could get the
two rooks get the two hooks here that is
technically now trick him yeah I could
have won that much easier in a much
easier way
this will very very likely be enough but
it could have been a lot easier
yeah even had a fork yeah okay didn't
didn't didn't didn't see it at the
moment okay
right now all night I've got time 30
points behind to Harry Joseph funny so
we're now Knights is going for a weird
Ben Oni weird to me what a Muslim
I tried to play the santur rupee one oh
really it's tough to say
taking also might be good now we have
transposed into very closed Kings Indian
type of position and I have to make sure
that I get something on the Queen side
yeah thanks for the follow
I have no clear reputation of critics be
true what is it super crazy move to play
maybe you don't know ok ok yeah Black
has got b6 or b5 maybe I don't really
mind that him
it makes opening this up makes me I
won't play a little bit easier trying to
get the night to 85
let's see 95 next okay that's not really
a threat Jim if I think I have blood
rev3 oh my god okay it doesn't see it
could have just taken the night we've
just taken the night okay
so let's jump in
I know what g5 is some bishop trap but
can do this and now before it's close to
working if I do it now we can probably
sacrifice the exchange so maybe put more
pressure on the airport and prepare
before there's one thing definitely in
my favor that's the time I don't have
much my many pieces there on the Condor
King side which is a problem
Bishop d8 was strong maybe now I have to
make sure that I'm not getting mated
which could easily happen I haven't
played it well but he's taking along
lots of time
I didn't see that coming
this is not nice defending this position
but campaign Heat he played like I
usually do quite okay but too slow I'm
not too worried about people possibly
cheating and because it's a very long
tournament and there will be complaints
during the tournament so if anybody is
really doing something fishy they might
get banned right in the middle of the
tournament yeah there was a an Evans
gambit you have a white and I don't
really know is that dangerous doesn't
look very dangerous to be honest Knight
d4 d5 t5 there's Bishop to e7 okay okay
I can do something conservative maybe
this is wrong it's not too bad it cannot
be too bad trade some stuff when you are
material up
so I have I'm still this I have this
extra point from the very beginning yeah
no this is now tricky Bishop c4 is a
threat I can't take it there's no reason
not to just take everything the bishop
is also hopes dominating the night I
don't think it's that bad
the heavens come but getting really bad
bet assessment and in the chat it's not
that terrible
likewise compensation is is quite quite
decent maybe I don't think that blackest
is much better or anything but he's very
okay okay so at least on 7th place yeah
really tough we getting a bad games in
the way of progressing even further
I'm not sure if this is the right the
right way to do it yeah I think this is
actually good for white
yeah it's all forever if the opponents
play well I always feel like something's
over there yeah why do they play well
now sometimes they do Wow he opens it up
with no development okay what now an IDE
b5 something I would just take maybe it
works out for black yeah Bishop d6 I
don't know if I have a fantastic reply
to that
probably after play nineties the
nightshift form that I actually did plan
I know it looks a bit weird but this
will win more time later
kingi to g5 so g5 he has to go back
before is to go to c5 I guess is there
some kind of tactic here like before
maybe or something before no terribly
complicated
okay let's play a somewhat simpler
animals
I get to be seven now does he have
anything else that Knight to e5 hmm Wow
why is he thinking okay it should be
flow let's get this into the game I know
this is actually blundering g5 okay
shouldn't do that very complicated
position my job in real life is actually
what I'm doing doing chess mostly
teaching some streaming and writing
stuff doing videos kind of everything
that she can do which is related not
playing that much actually about
competing for any any prize money
he just Castle yeah why not
he just castled
that's a really really tough position to
play
to hold for becoming a chess teacher I
don't know what to hold is them I think
I'm doing this is a decision that
depends on many factors age being one
and I guess some trouble moving is
pieces I'm really not more active
okay taking this doesn't work this work
so usually it looks very weird but it's
strong okay doesn't have a check okay
maybe that was a decent game I don't
know I've looked it looked interesting
at least okay
getting some points under my belt
41 placed like me is that a good thing
probably not place exactly what I
suggest in my rabbit one what's going on
spamming going on no spam yeah
not so happy with this Ryan can actually
take yeah why doesn't it better
I haven't been to creation for a long
time just for very very short to get to
the to the plane in Zagreb but I have
been known to Slovenia tons of times
Slovenia is my standard destination for
the summer vacation I'm going there
every year now for a long time and I'm
going to go again this year
I usually go to
oh gosh got slaughtered on the other
creation border actually make any sense
you know yeah that was extremely boring
but what can you do
poopy now I know I could beserk but I'm
currently I think in quite a good
playing rhythm that same and I don't
want to disturb it
okay trying to try to play for a five
and under standard attack it's maybe a
bit fishy
so I'm out for Knight g5 going form
quick made quick wins would help
definitely
really the dead did blacken some are
survived that's hard to believe
so he will take it and then what Bishop
g7 1 or we should have made some flame
Bishop g7 the king can take somehow this
is not a wind doesn't feel very fair but
it seems what it is okay
now maybe you ok I have one immediately
that that maybe was better do this
immediately yeah I had night h7 but just
just a pawn
I don't know if that helped come on more
pieces than the attacker threatening
this for example that looks dangerous
now you're very dangerous and then it
said maybe was good but I felt like I
need more more attacking power like a
struggling now to find a move
I can also take with us home
threatening Queen f7 maid
no curtains I guess
yep that's curtains bling doesn't work
pling it really doesn't work a pretty
decent rating for a place 30 no dummy
philidor's defense playing for Knight f5
year this is a standard idea in those
positions Queen to c4 is interesting I
don't know if this is a good way to do
it but sometimes this gets extremely
annoying I tried to do that my pieces
are a little bit loose zone I wonder if
he has something good now or something
concrete we'll see what happens
yeah hello to all of you in the chat I'm
I'm reading like with one eye but I'm
focusing more on the actual play at the
moment so what's going on here 95 maybe
huh
ok let's get this back for 95 or or just
95 yem the 95 is already a pretty good
move
[Music]
okay thank you fine I can take here you
know but it's probably not enough
ninety-five a bee Bishop of seven it's
not enough I think doesn't feel like
it's enough before is is annoying
hmm my one point before no I'm not sure
this is a good solution but my time is
was starting to tick down so I needed a
decision on simply my ideas are to take
and push the six
okay so g5 No
okay I am covering this for the moment
cover c2 and now try to double on the
e-file for p7 Lass's very logical way of
doing it
Queen to b6 however I think no this may
be this I don't want to want the Queen
to come to spy six or so and maybe plays
rook e5 I mean it would be a bit silly
this blunder but maybe it happens then
d6 check because it's the same motif
that we had earlier might happen I also
like to play f3 to make the rooks look a
little bit less less problematic he's
actually attacking us home don't don't
talk should be bit surprised by that I
didn't feel didn't feel like I'm so slow
or that he is so quick but somehow I'm
down on time okay seven still trying to
do that
May's got Quincy find always for the
trade
it's a bit lame but the time is just
hugely in my favor sorry I cannot ask a
sophisticated question in that
tournament
[Music]
okay I'm sorry the well it's impossible
for me to answer such a complicated
question during them during this the
stream also I find it weird that you
feel the banker repertoire that I
released is boring if you think this is
boring then you have a some sort of
issue I mean because it's an extremely
sharp repertoire I mean like the
sharpest that you can possibly play like
if you feel you need to need something
sharper then usually have to play
something completely terribly unsound
okay so cutter large horses my opponent
seemed
yeah - hello to all of you who started
to watch other cards Nakamura Mitch how
is the situation down they what do they
play now by the way today I know that
it's some sort of blitz but what time
control five minutes
what are they doing or something in
between
yeah going for a funnier check fast
repet okay what is that I know that it
looks extremely funny but yeah it is
kind of interesting
okay so we can himself a little bit and
the cars on our camera matches Sam is
not on a server they play they play in
Norway chess960 not even sure where they
play it looks like I don't know a museum
or something looks like an interesting
place
okay so here we go I had a four actually
missed that one
okay I'm trying trying to play Bishop g4
Knight f3 but I wonder if this is a move
actually pin wolf looks looks annoying
that's so easy um to UM Pinder's just
network has overtaken me by by by what
12 points
you see buzzer king every game and
people play whatever against sim or what
probably him I don't know it's weird I
was ahead of them very clearly and now
it's more than ten points ahead of me 58
points okay so what's the deal here I
can't go with d5
looks good
therefore I would be to know that that
must be pretty okay him what to do going
to activate the Queen
no I should to reform look - hmm
so he's saying I cannot take this
crazy maybe he's right okay
that was quick okay I've caught up a
little bit but what is he doing like was
working every game I came how do you got
him mmm
I think this is Freudian
I mean the Banco gambit is really the
sharpest opening you can play that is
still reasonable so if you stopped she
don't feel this is this is interesting
I don't know of course you can say you
don't like certain things about it or so
but boring is an uncommon
characteristics okay I tried to go for
this attack okay I'm trying to take him
I may be this this looks extremely
dangerous
so if black is defending this all the
power to him but I don't see this
happening I'm threatening like
everything f6 taking taking on h7 this
one for f7
Queen age six now augment baby this
okay where is the mate Knight f6
that looks pretty pretty deadly Queen
age ain't mate
mark him so it looks like I'm
establishing myself in the top ten at
least so was like our Hidden Dragon King
sorry I should play actually I don't
know if I should preserve this maybe I
should have in the French exchange I can
play really quickly but Kim and this is
one of those dull looking lines that can
actually be quite dangerous for black
you take this okay I'm a little bit will
be C some D for an i can i can i can
switch this yeah i can play a bit more
deform yeah I have the French exchange
in this in this repertoire
hey I know but if you get good positions
it's it's okay yeah I just have the
better position
yeah if you don't like the English
opening don't why do you buy the
repertoire it's it's a strategic opening
it's a very strategically focused
opening there are some sharper lines but
it's English it's not the King's gambit
yeah I played more afore
because I try to try to put more
pressure on the opponents in some way
also currently currently I've looked at
before so much for the repertoire work
that that I currently feel at home there
and I can play quickly going for oops
yes 95 or 96
now he's defending this quite well
actually by finding this very well yes
if I've I've got f5 as an idea
and what I am actually thinking of is as
a potential new project is to develop a
45 for black with very sharp lines
things that could be interesting to many
people are like let's say the Schliemann
gambit or things like that or maybe the
the the two nights yeah I think it's
it's often called fried liver a check
mmm this is actually a bit of a problem
[Music]
yeah sharp add sound I don't I don't
like to recommend fishing openings for
example the Schliemann is a perfectly
okay opening
a six is attacked yeah this is also this
aggressive before you five who black is
also something that is very much of
interest to me because I've played a
five for ages and I would like to have
some sharp lines in the repertoire
doubling on the seventh
thanks for the cheer
I really hope to win yeah to win the
rook somehow and get a bit of edge on
time here I'm playing the whole five
hours five hours is the idea
I'm already on for quite a while you are
came by yeah maybe I have to berserk
more but I don't like to
[Music]
okay so your team is playing a somewhat
rare line and quite well-developed
yeah maybe I need to preserve more
okay now I'm stood at the end I mean I'm
quite okay with my standing this is a
beautiful boring position
[Music]
this is an idea but I have this have
this still after castles
I usually absolutely don't mind
questions even longer ones but it's a
bit difficult if you play the tournament
and I mean this is not of at most
sporting importance but if I sit there
for five hours I want to try to for good
result so this is I'm bland during the
night oh my god
[Music]
I'm blonde during the night you are Kim
can take the night now which she does it
might actually be okay because of C 5 C
5 / should be 3 B should be 6 and all of
a sudden this is a deadly pin didn't
plan that
thanks for the Chia Joe Schwab I'm not
sure about the cheating frequency
I think I don't don't think you can say
it's more or less on this on that side
yeah see I think I win the piece down
the judicial piece
okay so fifth place yeah this is also
something that I like that only chess
aha aha
now we're talking
hmm okay interesting dominating the
tournament with this kind of opening
play amazing okay so I have a couple of
good options but let's do this
not sure about it
he does not really feel it does not
really feel like he thinks that what I'm
doing is any good am I think this is not
good for Wyatt not at all this is just
about holding maybe maybe maybe so I can
also check here
I'll just take be tuned okay I'll take
picture
why is that it moves
somehow this is still covered what is he
threatening mm maybe a check cannot wait
for ages I mean Queen a 5 there was
queen bee 8 mate
okay well I guess the other games he
played better he had a really great run
okay now Lazo that's the fourth place
going for going for the the Trump Trump
this line is one of those lines that I
never understood I always felt that must
be weird for white but looking at it
yeah when I when I looked at the bank
repertoire I looked at this also and it
is in fact quite okay for white this age
for business d5 I take this pawn
I'll take it
yes I'm mostly just just a pawn up but I
can castlelong which is a bit odd but I
think I can't do it so why he wants to
take now our Knight a5 yeah going to be
six a night to be six but don't think
it's a huge problem
[Music]
[Music]
look h1 something went terribly wrong
therefore wide so checking is possible
probably just this why I mean I wouldn't
have look actually there what what am i
doing it just finding the rook okay
seven how can we do this probably just
aim at the night with rookie to
questions you know are perfectly fine
and I do answer them very happily in the
in my regular shows when I'm let's say
playing a blitz against viewers and then
such but it's not such a great idea in
the context of such a show I just don't
have the time to to really read
everything okay um how do i how do I win
this I mean just take there or it looks
pretty nice hmm
how to our windows I don't see a maid
my king is still save Queen g7 I can
take or be too I mean that's the idea
yes I thought okay now each threatens to
check on the aid that's a very serious
issue
Wow still a little bit tricky
[Music]
how many chicks does he have
unbelievable
I came fighting closer yes Phyllis Capps
he had many chicks really had
yeah the privilege I should have won
that quicker actually it took her took a
really long while yeah this is the
absolute main line of the privilege very
dangerous with a seven I forgotten my
own theory
my own analysis I think this is wrong
Bishop a6 is actually wrong but I
couldn't remember simply couldn't
remember and this is a tricky thing in
three minutes yes if you if you have to
start to remember things and just don't
know them offhand that can be tricky
okay I think something like this could
be an autumn yeah I can take take him
[Music]
huh that didn't go too well they can't
just take c5 and I'm somewhat active but
not enough yeah maybe turn down the
quality yeah
upgrade the internet yeah that would
help but I think you're in Frankfurt
right and it's it's not like probably
the worst internet and that was a really
man-made kind of game pretty awful
pretty awful II played now you have to
pee yeah that's not that's not a big
problem I have to do that for right now
but I want to get points no time no time
for the bathroom in fact I will go for a
quick bathroom break shortly too much
information okay
I calculated one or two short okay I can
put it on the boats that you see a
blunder the rook okay I was a bad game
more Swift mas super tart yeah I will do
the full the full three hours for five
hours of the tournament definitely
look a six coming I don't know
three-minute is closer to bullet than
anything else
keep that covered and this is not so
terrible actually this can be quite
decent I have to get g6 Bishop g7 in and
stuff then I'm okay here look at the B I
can do this and Queen to f6 actually for
some activity 3 5 6 mmm
c5 is checked oh maybe just G's 1 6
actually yeah that's not bad
ready to take and then Bishop g7 oh
really
his weakening is positional Lord yeah
thanks for helping TDL
[Music]
not sure this not actually I'm sure ye
three is a good good resource that I
didn't see he cannot take now and that's
not not easy to handle cakes Bishop
takes wins the Queen like here a check
and then the Queen drops okay - maybe
yeah probably just taking this is good
faruk b1 push the pawn and I still
threaten we should be three here the
Queen has no squares no squares okay a
form I didn't see a form pawn to f4 yeah
this doesn't help queen is not trapped
okay yeah my bliss rating is also
getting to something normal him anyway
I'm closing in here and now I've got 10
points on chest network oh maybe he
deserved a bit too much many zeros Oh
direct splits caps director image this
is very popular
get 97 even more often than Bishop d7
even though Bishop d7 as the
long-established mainland five
interesting trying to get your ruler
pest type of position but I'm quite
quick I'm quite quick here on the
queenside probably still Knight f6 yeah
so I'm going to go for this okay it's
that way now I can't do this actually
this is this is quite a quite good cheek
I think you can get notifications by
notifications by following me on Twitch
okay I'm trying to fight trying to fight
here to keep keep his king in the center
Bishop a forward I go here first
okay the chick doesn't do much no can I
prevent castling somehow the bad chick
he has to move the king but doesn't help
him okay
I go I go to improve the night if he
decides to win this okay
like a knight he wants to move the
knight quite clearly yeah I was thinking
Knight is 3 M for Knight to d5 yeah I
was playing for that I wanted him to
take so that my bishop gets more active
Bishop to b3 ok
if you most of the night Queen f3 maybe
Queen f3 now I'm on f6 and f7 it looks
dangerous
okay Knight f6
huh yeah you can do that I can do that
absolutely
hmm strong move I guess I would have
this right it's chicken
it's chicken maybe just king to g7 Oh
tonight's its two key takes takes our
Stretton 27
only three points I only go three points
on
I just play game of the game no ah crap
and that c4 actually works my god
friggin mouth slip ah shoot
that was super unlucky I shoot crap
sorry
friggin mouse Libyan there was a big
difference a really big difference okay
this is eighteenth point 18th place at
the same opening gravity I mean where I
am from from Germany
get them get the same type of position
now then I had in the game perform this
is a better version quite clearly for
for black ah yes not good age three
that's night age five I guess now I'm is
played that quite badly
hmm yeah that was good
I've been opening flame
yeah
JK haiduk you can you can handle the
literature questions you're well
well-equipped to do that
I cannot look at questions like that at
the moment
each v is the one that he wants to blame
this could be good end badly
oh it might end badly page 525
[Music]
yeah I'm getting nicely I would play to
you by him just have a bad position
thanks for the Chia Sookie okay I'm
trying to just mess it up a little bit
and maybe I can irritate them at least
okay I can't chicken out all right I had
work yeah the irritation worked I can
shake on this check is not made I don't
see a maid Knight f7 works
[Music]
I didn't play that well now we can all
play me again probably
I always got to check them ah on the
back ring I didn't see that at all ah
okay while I was a game
ah first I got outplayed and I was
probably completely winning and then i
blundered it who not doing well not
doing well at the moment
okay then he should win the game I
haven't won a game for quite a while
[Music]
[Music]
hello to Lord Kinbote
very regular you are under on the stream
okay now he's trying to open this
understandably I wonder maybe f6 looks a
little bit hard but I don't want to open
the diagonal Jim why does some playing
this quite well I would say I can take
here now and take it
what a key actually because it was
hanging
and d3 hangs as well
yeah it looks okay I'm two pawns up it's
still a bit of a technical task try to
put the bishop on to your form
that sounds great if you're into really
long normals where nothing much happens
I have a recommendation for you it's a
good one
maybe I should have gone okay
I think GeForce may be what he wants to
do and here chicky always made us almost
almost me to not always made check check
to check a couple of chicks I can
actually go King g6 as rook g2 doesn't
work if he goes to f4 mate was the idea
which he prevented there any other mate
1994 maybe try this
[Music]
[Music]
looks difficult for him to defend this
stuff okay if the chick doesn't work
it's got no square right and there is no
made threatening discover check now
now I come on you're not serious
I shoot know what kind of nonsense what
utter nonsense now I will probably miss
this crap on time losing this game is
such a freaking junk
no okay okay I have to make a small
break him
you
okay I'm back again I just needed needed
the bathroom break badly okay so have to
somehow get back into the hunt and it's
it seems difficult yeah somehow I
stumbled into an open Sicilian which I
did not really want it to play in the
first place but anyway
okay these things can happen giving up
some material not intended not going to
tell you any any nonsensical story of
that being a sacrifice it wasn't but I
hope to still ask some questions here
not sure it is such an easy win
[Music]
hmm Knight takes simply oh okay you have
to have played the beginning of this
game lagging completed yet he probably
thought he can play whatever and but
it's not so simple I think I came 96 he
has the chick it doesn't look a super
forcing you can also just take I mean
maybe this isn't too bad
I'm not super sure what I'm threatening
probably to take on the age that's a
threat
[Music]
maybe just Bishop g5 feel I have the
check of course but and it's made
actually it's checkmate that was also a
threat would launch his net orcas who
were taken me account it's crazy
okay it's not a huge surprise that is
overtaking me because I didn't score I
know last couple of games
Dominic W is the opponent like a little
bit more time habit
hmm okay
it looks quite comfortable for Wyatt
maybe I'm overlooking something dynamic
some dynamic resource that that he has
but don't see it currently and then I
should be a little bit better him near
that is taken from which is not much
admittedly it's just a slight advantage
with the bad bone structure that black
ass will see an apron weak that's very
technical kind of position but and I
don't think they get longer and longer
but this is just the yearly tournament
which is probably supposed to be longer
than like weekly monthly and so on the
long chains of numbers yes Jean Jacques
has answered it
okay are taking c5
it looks a bit odd I'd move
before I can actually take in which I
didn't see
nice or I can do it stupid the taking d1
yeses
well there is a self pin crazy
completely lost track them
and also somehow somehow my position
feels a little bit loose like it like
something is not not quite right I
cannot really pinpoint what it is
oh Christ
[Music]
nice check didn't see can't said the
position of the draw losing this is crap
oh my I already have a better bet time
there and this is this guy on first
place is playing so many games he must
be Zerg everything Wow Wow okay Chuck
Hood frequent opponent and usually
simply killing me despite all rating
differences
okay Sicilian okay this is nothing
special I mean he's played it in a quite
non theoretical way but it's not too bad
I tried to use the square on D form okay
but she allows Knight to d5 s the idea
[Music]
here try to play here against the pawn
structure
okay I'm stopping ePHI for the moment my
ideas root before my pawn structure is
really better just that the King has a
little bit weak ah
that's him yeah first place is probably
impossible to get yeah this guy is
winning all his games even though he got
killed pretty badly when we played
maybe I can get white into some sort of
suits one probably not possible
I actually have an idea should go to g6
and then go age 5 driving might still
not know not to draw come on don't want
to make it drawn but actually this was a
bad move I just recognize that after age
5 he can actually take happened okay I
can't do this which is a hard way to
play for win but maybe I'm playing for a
loss yeah it's very much possible
so damn
it's probably draw with best play
[Music]
I hope I'm not screwing it up which
could happen
oh yeah I cannot win oh my god ah and
win a game like in eight games or
something this is crazy this is crazy
and somehow I have to start them kind of
a role again it will it work perform
mundo okay let's let's go back to basics
f5
yeah probably you're right sure could -
you had a pretty bad pawn structure
sometimes this is not enough to win I
don't know it was my problem there I
would have I did something wrong
yeah now he is taking a long think it
sounds it's a bit funny because I mean
he went for for this very willingly with
f5
Pontius was an idea actually
[Music]
okay so there's all kinds of things now
this is this is easy every age three
that's crazy really to us
so if I take he and on aged seven takes
Queen cakes
I really have problems at the moment
focusing Samara I have very good
positions but somehow I don't get get
wins out of them okay come on really
okay if I don't win this one I might as
well quit the whole thing but okay
whatever it's an exchange
okay so let's focus this is not maybe
not the easiest conversion ever let's
take this
ninety-two I'm redoing this badly badly
badly
ah come on I mean I know this is a long
tournament but I don't have to play like
a complete [ __ ] which I currently do I
really do eighteen seconds from this
position it's so crazy
that's so crazy what I did I [ __ ]
made wrong
yeah I had 10 seconds or something oh my
god crazy I have got I won the second
place now or the second page okay
yeah I have a an excellent French
defense now okay it's almost reading 96
and it's just develop
I can't just take be too many more
should have thought about it a little
bit at least its cover it
[Music]
I'm not helping our playtest but this is
true for the last 10 games really not
doing well really wonder if it is the
length of the whole thing then I'm that
I'm getting tired or anything because
playing wise I should be clearly on in
the top top places
mmm that's good a3 coming
you know every play I've played longer
and over the board tournaments so I'm a
little bit surprised that I'm suffering
so much here yeah I can take him for
loops yet again if I don't win that one
[Music]
even though black blunder despair David
it's still not a totally easy win at
least not for me
rook air-five somehow this isn't all
that clear life isn't fair is it I don't
get it yeah
I don't get it yeah I'm good I'm good
it's crazy just crazy that was that was
a weird decision
crazy okay no I have to have to pause
for just a moment I mean that's really
too terrible
[Music]